after questioning the point of his
dearly coronavirus briefings because of
critical media coverage after not
holding a briefing over the weekend
after initially canceling the one on
Monday the president appeared in the
Rose Garden to update the country he
revealed plans to help States to ramp up
testing to reopen the country we're
releasing additional guidance on testing
to inform the states as they develop
their plans for a phased and very safe
reopening our blueprint describes how
states should unlock their full capacity
expand the number of testing platforms
established monitoring systems to detect
local outbreaks and conduct contact
tracing a number of states have
announced plans to reopen although no
one is expecting a return to what was
once normal we're taking steps to
understand it's gonna be a new world but
we have to be realistic that we can't
wait 18 months to have a vaccine and
just tread water people want to see
forward progress in Georgia and other
states some restaurants are reopening
some movie theaters are also back in
business but all under serious
restrictions we've got we've paper menus
that are disposable versus our place
back plastic ones some places like
Washington DC have renewed lockdown
orders at least until the middle of next
month and people seemed to be complying
across the country that are also reports
of people ingesting disinfectant after
the president asked last week if it was
possible that could kill the virus his
comments led to widespread condemnation
and his decision to halt the briefings
over the weekend asked the boater on
Monday he brushed off the question
they've seen a spike in people using
disinfectant after your comments last
week I know you said they were sorry I
can't imagine why I can't imagine why
yeah I can't imagine I can't imagine
that the president now believes the u.s.
is on course to see your own 70,000
deaths from the virus a figure up by
10,000
his previous prediction Alan Fisher al
Jazeera Washington